you know me trying to put the pieces
together
always what's up
gentlemen how you doing Uncle Joey
what's up you sexy
[__] thanks Fredy appreciate
that I wasn't talking to Lee I'm talking
to you two other no I didn't say that I
didn't say that I didn't say that I
didn't say
that
you always blame me it's Tuesday
December the 5th Uncle Joey's here the
checkin is brought to you bu freeze pipe
what the champion smoke listen getting
high is supposed to be relaxing but when
you're inhaling billion billion degrees
smoke and coughing up a lung you got a
problem like your Uncle Joey guess what
there's a solution get the freeze pipe
it's a glycerin chamber and it comes in
every piece that you pop in the freezer
for about an hour and when you're ready
to see the devil boom you put it on the
pipe as the smoke passes through it it's
cool down by over 300 degrees for the
iciest hits you'll ever it's like you're
in Aspen Colorado and you're floating
and all a sudden you're just picking up
Snow and smoking through the snow can
you imagine smoking through the snow get
your life together no matter how you
like to smoke bong dab rggs whatever
freeze pipe is here to chill every out
so you crazy Savages can get high all
day long without burning your throats
made with durable glass these little
mules of bongs will withstand years of
use how do I know because it took three
years for the one to break that and it
my friend dropped it he picked up the
one [__] piece without he didn't know
that had a chamber my bad but anyway
you'll never breathe harsh smoke again
guaranteed shop the smoothest pipe
bubblers bongs they even got a a blunt
freeze pipe for you for you guys who
likes blunts go to the freeze pipe.com
and pressing Cod Diaz for 10% off your
entire order that's the freeze
pipe.com
Cod Diaz for 10% off your entire order
Merry Christmas turn off your TVs run
for your lives it's over they didn't put
you on this planet just to give up if
Uncle Joey could do it I the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back
to how you doing duck you have no idea
what happened to me tonight guys I had a
great day I had lunch with my brother
went to gave blood went to the gym I had
to make calls today and I get home about
3: and it's the same old song and dance
I'm [__] dying at three I wait for
Mercy to come in I talk to her for a
little while tells me about a homework a
day and then uh as soon as she goes to
do homework I slip into the bedroom and
it's Snappy Noo-noo
time every day at
three every day at three but today I was
really like lately I took I think I took
one nap last week but I took this little
[__] nappy Noo-noo I get up about
4:30 I'm like whoa I gotta get up and
get ready for these edibles but when I
got up I was out of it and I slept good
last night I got seven and a half last
night I went to bed at 11 and I woke up
at
5 the first [__] time to pee that's
like a record for Uncle Joey
right so I I get up at 4:30 I I brush my
teeth I list the reading I wash my face
you know the whole thing and I come
downstairs I drink some water and all of
a suddenly I'm starting to [__] you
know like when you're about to puke
really yeah I start you eating the
Edibles or you were just sitting there
no no no I hadn't eaten the Edibles yet
oh [__] and then the next thing you
[__] know I'm you know I'm over there
with my shirt off sweating Peru justly
and dog I was going to call you at like
6:15 and go I don't know about the night
guys and I got up I took a tendous
[__] dump the whole time I was gonna
puke and I drank a uh IV liquid IV dog
within 10 minutes the phone started
ringing I'm talking to
people you know so it's beautiful thing
that's how quick I got I got a little
buzz to me I got my lunch today
I had a
steak and chicken and
rice Jesus
Christ I got a new toy now you know what
I'm saying I went to light I took such a
disgusting [__] I had to put a candle up
and I couldn't find a light I don't feel
like walking to the garage so I blasted
it with this the candle almost melted I
don't even know why I don't even know
how I got I don't even know what this is
hold on let's be honest let's all goad
you you love that lighter and you're
lighting you've never had a candle I
guess you did have a candle in the
office I think you love you just love
lighting [__] with that
lighter you know me I'm a I'm a whatever
the [__] you call those people uh not a
klepto whatever a pyro you know pyro
yeah just I started pyro my first career
at the age of five I was a pyro I was a
pyro from five to like [__] seven
until the fight apartment came and that
was it that was the end of my pyro
career from 5 to seven Jesus yeah yeah
now like when I I'm so like it's it is
crazy to me that you don't do dabs I
would think dabs would be right up your
alley listen man once if I need a blow
torch to get high it's time for a
different [__] party you might as
well shoot the heroin in go to Saudi
Arabia pick up a pound and take your
chances like Midnight
Express holy [__] I need a B in my
[__] house to get high and Stu and
yeah people say it's cleaner I get
it but I'm old school listen to that
lung [__] if I do 10 dabs now the
lung will be gone this motherfucker's
holding on pretty soon I'll be on a
list pry should not be on a list for
[__] Al I have to wait for a trombone
player to die or something like that are
you really gonna be on a list I don't
know but you never
know you know Anything Could Happen
those D are crazy they they're [__]
nuts and they they make them stronger
and stronger and you know I just I I I
like to get high to enjoy it I like to
the taste of the marijuana I'm a [__]
old school type of dude you do it for a
reason listen I've quit every [__]
thing I've
done and I'll tell you what I don't even
think about quitting marijuana I take
some days
off I you know
some nights I don't feel like smoking
and that's
fine some mornings I leave here at 8 and
you know I don't get high till
2230 so bam it's it's life you know but
you don't have you've never once
considered quitting
weed why it's the last piece of what and
who the [__] I am I'm a [__] old [__]
now I don't do nothing I don't mug I
don't do nothing I don't call bookies no
more
I don't do
nothing when were you calling bookies I
don't know I'm just telling you that you
know wheels
so in my world right now and it's been
like that for years it's like when I
call my daughter at night she comes down
here with a [__] teddy bear it's a
purple one a big one you know and I'm
like Merc and I don't even say nothing I
can't say nothing to to you about that
but it's like my teddy bear
it's the last
piece of I went to the gym the other day
and I was working out and I put on Pink
Floyd Dark Side of the Moon why I don't
know it was there I haven't listened to
it and there were parts of that one
that's the first time I ever [__]
tripped it what did you do for that
one I had a h acid and I a sixpack of
Michelob I was about 13 you know 13 yeah
and I [__] went home I was so high
about four I did the ass like at one on
a Sunday and I was so [__] high I
went home like about
six at night at night I got home I tried
to get home for din before dinner and I
[__] went into that room and I had
these posters like basketball I was a
geek you know I had like Leed Zeppelin
and like Michael Corin and the
McDonald's allar you know
and I'll never forget at one point I
said [__] it this ass is too strong and
I had an eight track player and I had
dark side of the moon on at track and I
popped that [__] in and all of a
sudden I started seeing
things and I was like Wow because Pink
Floyd had mixed in with my thoughts and
and what I was seeing on the poster and
the next thing you know man I got up the
next morning like I slept the whole
night and when I woke up I I puked in
the middle of the night but I didn't go
to the bathroom I just twisted my head
and puked on my
shoulder when I woke up the next morning
I had a dead piece of [__] gum and my
shirt smelled like a [__]
Brewery but anyway who gives a [__]
about
that let's talk about you Lisi how was
the weekend in Kansas city
congrat thank you very much it was
fantastic it was one of the best
weekends I've had in a while it was
really uh it was really really fun talk
to me what happened Thursday night break
it down so it was just a really I've had
like pretty good weekends recently all
right um but like you know like there's
always a show or two like that doesn't
go the way you want it to go no you got
five shows you're gonna die two out of
five well this one and that's what
usually happens and this one pretty much
every show there was one show that I
didn't do as well as I would have liked
but it was still like it was a just a
very good weekend the staff was really
amazing like the the man like the
coolest part or one of the coolest Parts
was like the manager sat me down and
like took me through her plan for
features and like what it would be like
to work there um what she looks for in a
future put like putting shows together
and it was like just cool to
see like someone's actually putting like
like thought into it and like how what
it would look like if I went back and it
was just very
[Music]
cool listen when I got into comedy there
were a lot of Comedy clubs at the time
that had people who talked to
you you know and the
mid90s comedy club Owners talk to you
today I or yesterday or one a couple
days ago one of the guys I used to talk
to a lot about the essence of
Comedy was a guy who did comedy did
sketch got married and he moved on to be
the comedy club manager in his name was
Carl
wov he was there Mondays and Tuesdays
for the open mics oh that's cool he
cared and then there were comedy club
Owners or man general managers that they
cared and a lot of them knew me spoke to
me but they didn't care for my type of
comedy at the time and that was
cool at least they told you that right
absolutely but one of the that had it
when I came back in '94 was The Comedy
Works in Denver they had a writing class
on Tuesdays and then from the writing
class you went down to the open
mic okay and it was and then after the
writing after the open mic you talk to
the comic again and he was a good good
dude his name was Matt something we'll
Remember by the end of the show so I
understand what you're saying by a
manager took the time it's a lot of
[__] fun man they are some good
people still [__] left in the
business yeah and her name is Amanda and
she was laughing because she said you
called her during the P She said you
were like one of the only ones and you
would call her and just make sure she
was okay and it was just yeah it was uh
it was cool to see it was just nice have
like because I on Wednesday before I
left on Thursday I had like a terrible
set it was like I was just one where
like people were just staring at me and
I fought them a little bit and got them
a little bit but it was just to go and
then just Josh's crowds are amazing so
it's I've been very lucky it it was it
was also cool
because I I wrote a joke with joshh on
Thursday and I just did I rewrote it and
I did it every show Friday and Saturday
and like just working on it like cuz I
normally would never have the balls to
do that that I I always almost always do
new stuff only at open mics and to
T to test something out
um brand new was was pretty
cool it's always very cool when a joke
works yeah but what's cooler is when you
work with
somebody that you kind of
have a camaraderie with that actually
Josh and I did that 30 years ago from 95
from the time I met John like in 97 and
98 we worked together 96 and 97 we knew
each other's act and he would tell me
things I would tell him things and I'll
never forget by moving to Los Angeles we
lost half that act because it was
Seattle attitude Seattle based you know
so it's really weird how even in the
beginning in La we're very helpful to
one another and that's something that
you remember forever that's why we're
still so very tight after all the years
and all the LA drama he got it and I got
it how important we were to each other
at one time in our
lives but uh it's very nice to see that
he's doing it with you and his son now
oh it's been so much fun and it's just
like the the level that he's at is just
like just so like the way he looks at
writing and Performing has been very
cool and seeing him and Jake have a
great time together it's really Jake for
people who don't know he's like 26y old
son and they they do a ton of stuff
online they have a podcast but they he's
been doing standup for seven months and
he's doing like 10 to 15 up front and
doing like a great
job
okay listen he grew up around it when
you grow up around it it's like you you
sat there like [__] Johnny mommy
eating edibles but the whole time you
were listening you were listening and
that's very important to see people
don't have one of the guys I always talk
about is Jason Lucas one of my dearest
friends in La I see Jason Lucas I stop
what I'm doing I give him a big hug he
gives me a big hug because we go back to
the Comedy Cabana in Myrtle Beach South
Carolina 199 [__] seven maybe no
yeah 97
98 and he came up to me he was like an
MC or an open micer and he goes how's LA
and I'm like here another guy is going
to tell me he's moving out there he's
like I'll be out there in two months and
I'm like okay I'll see out there say
hello at the store and one night he's in
the back
watching and he did that every night he
paid the 15 bucks to go in there and he
just watched all those comics and it was
a whole different set of comics back
then there it wasn't Bill Burr or you
know nothing like that it was Rogan Paul
Mooney you know and then six months
later he became a
doorman and then two years later him
Steve Simone Rick
Ramos they became regulars and I was
there that night and dog it was one of
the best nights of my life just seeing
Steve Simone got
drunk really oh he was crying you know
he gets
emotional that was the biggest night of
his life Rick Ramos was on the phone in
the hallway with his mother crying and
just to see that I was like damn I wish
I had a mother to share my experiences
but just to see that was so
cool the camaraderie in
comedy is one of the best [__]
camaraderie you'll
ever for
me for me there's something about you
have friends and then there's certain
Comics
that we just have a
camaraderie you know and he may live in
LA and I live in New York but when we
see each other we give each other the
load down and we know what's going up if
I hear about something I call him if he
hears about something he calls me but
then to take it back that early when you
were typically
broke because me and Josh were doing
comedy
for we'd split up $140 three
ways for for a show yeah we did like if
he had a a feature spot in Portland
Oregon and he was making
300 he'd take me with him I'd sleep in
the room next to him and [__] go do
spots because I wasn't doing anything
else that's
awesome and he throw me 50 bucks
whatever I wasn't going down there
looking for the money we did that all
all the time when I lived in Seattle we
did that for two years after like six
months any gig iy had he got and any gig
he got I got and it was a constant and
when you're an open mic or going into
that
feature you'll never forget that like I
you look at me a fat [__] now there was
a time when I wouldn't like at lunch I'd
eat ramen and all I'd wait for is for
that show so I could go to the comedy
club and eat something plus get money
after the show and we go to mccomic and
Schmidt's and chop up 50 bucks it was a
$2 menu back
then you know that's why I'm so loyal to
mam M schmidtz whenever we go to San
Jose that's the first place we went to
after
[__] that place the Italian
place it's crazy because like a lot of
comics talk about like being competitive
or like and even on podcast I hear
comics talking about like how
competitive it is but it is also like I
don't at least at my level I haven't
really experienced that like it's all
been like everyone's super nice you go
out to eat after you have a drink after
a show it's not like you're taking it
from
anybody you go to an open mic you go to
a couple open mics you're your friends
with a a good comedian in your area
whether it's Denver Chicago
Boston and you go to open mics and you
know there's some open mics that are
better than
others yeah you know as you know there's
some open mics that uh you know are
whatever and then there's some open mics
that an audience goes that pay
attention you a couple bucks to drive
home you know it's a nice Open
Mic he puts up about nine people now
about the nine people he puts out
including yourself there's going to be
one person in there that it's you and
him he's a a good host strong Fe stting
to feature strong and you're in the same
position you got two
options you open up your heart to the
guy if he's a scumbag then [__] him but
if you open up your heart to him and he
opens up your heart to you remember two
heads are better than
one and that's where you learn like when
I started doing that with Josh
it taught me to learn how to work
together how it was like my daycare for
comedy I was at the fifth year sixth
year and now I was allowed to play in
the sandbox with the other Savages and
it just wasn't myself and him there was
a couple other people in our crew that
we Ron Rod long we breeded for one
another he was a headliner so if he got
a gig I was part of it and if Josh Wolf
didn't mind featuring he'd [__] take
the gig and guess what
the second show I'd switch with him and
I'd host and let Josh feature that's no
ego comedy but then you move to a
competitive place like Los Angeles right
right Los Angeles you start looking at
people that you met five six years ago
that couldn't follow you and now you get
to La and they're getting spots every
night right now you have to look at it
from a perspective of I can hate this
guy and there's not going to be one of
those guys there's going to be three of
those guys you've been doing you've been
doing comedy for eight nine years 10
years you know when you get to La you're
GNA not know the bill burds and [__]
like that because they bring their own
feature but you're G to know a majority
of comics and a lot of guys you thought
you were funnier than they're gonna be
kicking ass in that
way and that cuz like I can see it would
be annoying cuz I definitely get jealous
of people when they when I see some of
their shows but it's also sometimes when
I look at a comic and I and I think I'm
better than them and I see that they're
doing stuff I'm like oh then I can
definitely do it if well that takes time
like I said going over that
hump takes
time and once you get over that hump and
you're in La again you open your heart
to your friends if they
scumbags that's it you don't throw you
know you don't throw them [__] no more I
was thinking about a gig I got this
audition I wanted to be on the show so
bad called like Kingpin or something on
NBC it was the guy that we did the
podcast with from Scarface got it okay
it was
uh Emilio Rivera it
was uh Danny tryo this is I'm talking if
it's
2024 this has to be 2002
2003 wow I never forget getting this
audition and going Doug I'd be [__]
I'd be I would love to get this it's a
guest
star I would love to get this this would
but the more and more I read it I saw
two people I saw Louie
Guzman and I think he was on the show
already I don't I don't know cuz this
was like one of the early episodes like
episode three I had one of the biggest
chances of my life you know like going
in after episode three but the whole
time Le I didn't feel comfortable
because the guy for this role was Rudy
Moreno okay I just felt
Rudy I just felt [__] Rudy for this
episode and I got in there and I learned
the audition I went to a coach at that
time my coach was 20 bucks he was a
black guy that was brilliant gay guy but
he had HIV I don't know what happened to
him I lost [__] touch with him he
taught an acting class and he taught and
he then if he liked you he you know he
worked with you individually God bless
his soul wherever he is I remember I had
an audition I got late and he met me at
one in the morning oh no [__] yeah I
lived on like I don't know Hollywood and
shreder or Hollywood somewhere and he
lived like maybe blocks away on
go okay go to the Denny's by go and I'll
work with you and I remember that we
went over it inside but then we went to
the parking lot it's two in the morning
and inh him rehearsing in a parking lot
people walking past us it was [__]
tremendous that's a really cool story I
don't know if I ever got the roll or not
I don't remember but I just remembered
it now as I was telling it to you
because I called him a couple times late
8 o'clock
you know in those days you would get an
audition at
7 7:15 they call you and go Joe we have
an audition for you at 11 o'clock
tomorrow you already got a spot at the
store at
11:30 right and you got to go down there
to pick up your 15 bucks God forbid and
I I know obviously know what a coach
does but like what why do you like
getting a coach for an audition at that
point I
needed I needed to book [__] and acting
class was great I was taking cold
reading and and uh scene study class and
that was
great but you with a
coach he shows you things that he opens
up things for you that you're not
seeing like little things like I want
you to think about the moment before you
go in that room and call that woman a
[__]
[__] what are you feeling you know like
stupid [__] he'll highlight things for
you on that paper that only an
experienced actor would see that you
don't see still because you're green
it's very
helpful it's
very and did you ever was there like a a
role that you did that you had a coach
that like really
helped I had a couple coaches one was
later on and she was pretty
expensive but I remember
like it was like an investment like it
was like you're getting this rooll for
scale plus
10% let's draw a round figure up there
at 700 bucks
right and uh what the [__] I can never
adjust this it's a nightmare right there
let's say you're getting 700 for the day
now out of that you got to pay a
commission that's $70 you got to pay
taxes
all right I don't know maybe you clear
480 right let's
just she wanted like $100 for a half
hour
Jesus
so think about
it it was
uh
very like I went to her like I remember
going to her two times in a row and
booking two co-stars
and I was pretty impressed because the
investment was worth it but by that time
that was a lot of money this lady
coached like [__] real people you
know how I mean how come you you don't
think there's that in standup or is
there that I haven't heard of that
what's that hold on one second before we
get the standup and the craziness that
comes at standup one of the best things
about doing standup where I [__] up
was the Laugh Factory
in
La offers
counseling on Monday nights to comics
for the low end of the SAG whatever it
was like 29 bucks and I guess she had
worked with people before and a lot of
people were going to see her and I made
an appointment I checken out and I wish
I would have gone to see her at that
point I wouldn't ended up burnt out or
whatever sometimes the same happens in
life check out my thing for
betterhelp.com you're going to love it
betterhelp is who I join when I got here
and now boom I'm [__] Tip Top myo
check this
out what's up dog I'm doing great buddy
all right let's do it how are you
feeling okay yeah I feel great all right
all right let's go so we were talking
about why doesn't it work for
standup
when you ask that
question I have to answer it from two
way you know I don't [__] know for me
it wasn't going to work for me
unless listen something that I learned
from Phil Jackson was when he was a
player I wanted to stab him in the heart
he was the [__] worst Nick in the
world but you know guy that guy went on
to win I don't know six championships
with two teams or something like that he
saw the game from a different
perspective and I like that and so I'm
coming to you from twoo I can't really
agree with you I can't take somebody's
money to coach him
Lee unless I really really like what
they're doing on stage and after a point
of coaching I have to manage
them because if I think they're that
good and they stayed with me for six
months and I'm not raping nobody you
know I mean just being and it doesn't
even have to be you but if it was
someone like a comic that I trusted or
someone who I
trusted I would love that like I'm so
jealous in a very good way of Eric and
everyone who gets to be like a door guy
at the store because like there's an
actual path like being a halfway decent
standup you would
think and there's nowhere else that's
like like the only place so if there was
a place where I could go and get like
advice that I trusted on like not even
just St up but like career stuff how
about a
gay I've I've been there Eric took me
there going there with like some T tight
time and tell him you need some advice
help that's not the advice I'm looking
for bust out the
lollipops yum yums Before Christmas
[__] oh that's bad advice the best
closest thing to that is the closest
thing to that is is
hoping that when you move wherever the
[__] you live New York
Miami Los Angeles wherever the [__] you
live that you have two other guys maybe
three that you really trust for me it
would be
Felipe you know Willie
Barcena and like Adam burnhard from the
store he's a really he teaches standup
at the store and he used to dear friend
of mine and I remember him dissecting
stuff for me for some people for them to
come up to me and dissect my [__] I just
saw you bomb three times in a row right
and you're gonna come up to me and put
the kiss of death on
me
jokes so I I don't know I got to see
where you're coming
from the guy Matt Woods who taught the
writing class remember I told you I
remember his name yeah he ended up
becoming a coach for a couple
Comics uh you know I don't remember
their names right now one I
do
and I don't
know I'd rather manage you if you want
the way I would and make the choices for
you or help you make the
choices
then hey you make you pay me out of
pocket you follow I'm saying to you so
if we start for 90 days six months and I
see what I like as far as where you're
going you know at that level how you're
acting around that how you're acting
around that I'm GNA sneak up on you at
bars I'm G to sneak up on you on comedy
clubs I have to sit in the back and
watch I'm not gonna tell you I'm going
to see you I'm not there your balls
I'm going to know what time your
schedule is and I'm going to slip in the
back tell you a couple things and we'll
talk on Monday I'll get out of your hand
let you go get your dick sucked or
whatever it is you're GNA do I'm not GNA
go in the green room and hi how you
doing back in the day I knew kenis and
that doesn't do nothing for me but I
could help you know like yeah if I had
the time and stuff and you were
somewhere local or something I can't I
can't judge myself on a tape so I'm not
going to try to judge anybody on the
tape right I see when you walk in I
gotta [__] see your demeanor before
you get on stage but again most
importantly what happens because I'm
putting a big investment into you so if
I see you [__] stumbling out of there
a couple times I can't work then I have
to take your money because you're a
[__] [__] you're not looking at it
for what it is I'm not looking for John
Lenin I'm looking for because right now
listen I I really noticed something the
last 10 years I was doing comedy there
was nobody on the road with drug
problems oh wow like no comedians look
at all those clubs and all the comics
that went out every weekend they're all
connected and you heard little mumblings
there's one comedian that I love him
like a brother that's never going to
happen and I wish him I wish he you know
someday but besides that it's not
accepted
anymore to do drugs and be like out of
it on the road I don't need you coming
to my bar I don't need you coming to my
comedy club with your [__] feature
act and your [__] MC and five of your
buddies I don't appreciate you guys
drinking seven bottles of
tequila I don't need that and for your
[__] door guy to get into a fight
with my door guy I don't need your wife
to go out there and act like the first
lady of [__] comedy I don't need that
I got 20 other Comics I could come in
here destroy and I don't they don't even
say a [__] peep they're just lucky to
be paying them the money I'm giving them
you're coming in here acting like Led
Zeppelin In 73 it Ain gon paying out for
you it's crazy it's crazy how some
people take advantage like that but
think about you don't hear about com
listen when I when I was in comedy when
I got into comedy there was a lot of
comics were
problems I was one of them but I didn't
matter I didn't matter there was uh the
features and Headliners and then when I
became a
feature there was little Resurgence
again I still remember being a
[__] you know at at at my club in
Denver people snorting [__] tons of
Coke in The Green Room you know the
headline of bring a bag with them and
everybody back there doing yum yums I
was not part of the group that people
say they got paid in cocaine no I
remember one time I got money and they
gave us a bonus in
cocaine in Texas but that's when you
were doing comedy for the cartel you
didn't even know it Jesus Christ what do
you think why do you think it's where it
is now where like people aren't getting
[__] up is it just because you won't
get work I don't know it's a different
generation you know I don't know if Tim
Dylan drinks I don't think you know the
only guy I know that's a [__] nut is
Bert right B could do whatever the [__]
he wants in the club he can let himself
on fire oh yeah because gonna break the
record for Booze
anyway and he doesn't I I haven't heard
anything of him being like out of it at
any show Miss he don't miss shows he
don't cancel shows because he's hung
over Bert is the ultimate [__]
professional when it comes to that
[__] it is I was that was the only show
that I didn't love my set this weekend
was the show I was a little hung over
for and it was I was fine but in my
brain my brain just felt like a little
bit like not connected I don't know if
that makes sense I I'm gonna get to that
in a
second to finish that story I went to
this audition my dick was hard I walked
in there at a Monday at 10:00 a.m. it
was in the
valley in fact that building where I
went into it was close to where we lived
it was like up lauro Canyon make a right
like two door two blocks Down on the
Corner it was on top of a flower shop or
something like that okay yeah anyway I
walked in there [__] everybody was in
the room there were three people in the
room I read they liked the reading but
the one lady said to me I gotta be
honest with you you did a phenomenal job
you're just not right for this and I go
thank you I didn't think so either but I
didn't want to cancel but I just wanted
to grab a piece of paper I wanted to
tell you who is right for the job and
they looked at me and I go Rudy Moreno
and she goes who and then the one girl
went on IMDb and she goes yeah maybe I
go trust me it's him three days later
Rudy called me he got the job that's
awesome they called him right at the
house I would say I still remember his
number that's how many times I talked to
Rudy on the phone I got R I didn't get
Rudy a gig I got Rudy a [__] guest
star like that's when it was like $2,600
for a guest star
and I had a that's how I knew I was
opening up my door my thing something is
going to come my way now I just I didn't
fight for this because I knew it didn't
matter even if they they took me to
producers because uh whatever but anyway
who gives a [__] about me talk to me
about your adventure with the
mushrooms oh [__]
so Sometimes Late Show
Friday there there's a magical show so
we do mushrooms after I go on and we
have a great time
and the first half of the night was we
were just laughing the drive back to the
hotel the manager drove us home it was
awesome it was dying laughing but I got
up to my hotel room and for like the
first time ever like it went dark like
it was like just like the only way I
could think of describing it would be
like like Ultra ression and I've never
like it was I I ended up just listening
to the my set from that
night and it took me out of it like it
took my focus out of it so I was fine
but it was like I've never experienced
like just like like it was like and if I
let my thoughts go for a second it would
just go right back into it it was really
crazy never had that happen is has that
happened to you has it gotten dark when
I was
younger 1980 82 I was doing assd late
night and I would go home and then fuel
it with cocaine and that would light the
acid on fire and I'd play like Pink
Floyd de wall or and when you listen to
that [__] you know back then it took you
through a magnitude of
emotions like you cried you giggled you
laughed you cried and then you wiped
your tears giggling like I'm now you
know you're going through a [__] trip
yeah that I was going through the TV and
I hit that scene with then with Denzel
and Man on Fire which one excuse me when
he's in his room I didn't say excuse you
to you exuse me for burping uh he was in
his room and he's hammered and he's
doing all [__] I still remember doing
that on
acid really yeah acting like just having
a conversation with yourself so you're
in there deep you're deep in the murky
Waters you're going through [__] it I I
I'm not going to tell you I had a gun in
my hand with a no no that's not what I'm
saying but I still remember he was doing
it with a bottle yeah you know when I
saw that scene I really enjoy I go he's
hitting home right now because that's
what happens when you get high by
yourself and at one point in the night
the acid the cocaine the spe it becomes
just like yosis the alcohol you go into
like a [__] weird
psychosis it's enjoyable for some it's
not enjoyable for others it's scary you
wake up a little depressed in the
morning because how you acted in the
mirror the night
before I I I've never looked in the
mirror but yeah it was it was definitely
strange and like my brain like I slept I
I was up until like six I thought about
calling you for a second at like five I
was like should I call
Joey that [__] phone it's crazy wake
up in the morning and there's [__]
three Miss
calls you know people get hammered
friends of mine and dog I don't hear
that [__] thing ring at
all like right now when I finish with
this there's a football game I gota eat
dinner I'll plug this phone in I'll come
back here at 10: it's not like anybody's
calling me at 8 for auditions
anymore you know like I said to you 20
years ago 20 years ago from [__] 6 o'
to 7 you better be home with a pen and a
piece of
paper CU everyone will call you after
the like at the end of the day I be at
the supermarket with Terry and all a
sudden I get a [__] call hey I gotta
talk to you Jeff call me back in 15
minutes I have to pay the [__] Ralph
thing and we shoot home and I get in
what's going on listen you got a
callback for producers but I got you an
audition for something else it's your
call back is at 3:30 but this is at 3:
you know it was [__] but I told them
You' be there by 4 so you're gonna go
into the room first I already set that
up and then you're gonna shoot to Marina
del re I mean it was [__] like that [__]
then thir you got a showcase for CVS at
the impra like it used to be heavier
then I was younger I was involved in
more the older you get the old you know
your opportunities diminish nobody wants
to see on Dave letman unless you've been
on David lman since you were
22 wow okay you know unless you know
whatever they're looking for young upand
cominging Talent unless a guy like me
like Ron White puts out a tremendous HBO
special and now everybody wants to see
him which I think he'll do now Ron
White's back on the road I'm [__]
excited to see oh I know I bummed but I
never got to see him yeah he's back on
the road now I know he's doing San
Antonio and something else but I got to
tell you what what happened to me what
I'm got myself involved
in did you know tell I don't think
so me and a bunch of moms are taking
[__] six kids Friday night to the
Garden to see jelly
roll and a bunch of bad music that the
kids
like you're going to the garden
yeah so wait are you go
I I am in shock because I would have
never have guessed you would go to the
Garden I'm assuming you got pretty good
seeds uh jelly roll so I don't know
where he's going to put me but wherever
he puts his begas can't be choosy okay
oh that's cool that he's giving you
tickets yeah I mean I'll see I'll knock
it down Friday and see what the money's
at on Friday you know what's crack a
lacking with these [__] and then but
yeah and then we're trying to get three
other mother two other mothers and three
other kids tickets so they've been
online we've been talking chitchatting
so I'm just going to wait talk to my man
jelly and uh I'm you know what you ever
been excited about something like yeah
my when my daughter found out she put on
a costume from Olivia Rodrigo one of her
videos I wasn't I was down here and she
was up there jumping down talking to my
wife about it she was so excited she
banged her head on the kitchen cabinet
they had to put is she okay yeah she's
got a shine it today she was bleeding a
little
bit so that's deal Friday I was just
thinking like is this the first concert
you guys have been together yes we went
to like that show ching chang with the
Chinese people they do the acrobats and
you know we've been
through I don't think it's called ching
chang I forget what the the name but is
oh but that's pretty cool I mean we
talked for hours on the church about
like all the concerts you went to as a
kid oh yeah it's pretty cool that you
got because you didn't I don't think did
you ever go to one with your mom are you
[__] [__] I wouldn't take my mom
to a
concert
I'm I'm gonna take my mom to see [__]
Black Sabbath at the Garden are you
[__] crazy I don't know if you made
it my mom and I used to go like the
Globe CRS and the C that was the extent
of it and a lot of [__] me games
right oh yeah definitely that game so
that was the extent of it uh you know I
see little girls with the with the he
Hado you know what's the girl that's
popular now Taylor Swift yeah Taylor
Swift with the Taylor Swift hados and
their fathers have to take them you know
the tickets are two grand but you know
when you come to think of it they got
you on a string it's your kid it's you
know what I wouldn't do for me I'd have
like I wouldn't pay 10 years ago I would
want to go see Roger Waters with Ari we
got the assd the whole thing I told Ari
I got a preconceived number it's
200 200's the highest I [__]
pay and I got down there and nobody had
them less than that we went to eat it pH
leaps and we came home and watch the
movie we trip for a little while and the
train back and that was the end of it
nobody got their feelings hurt you know
but if somebody came to me for an
experience with my child yeah that's
just not like a lead Zeppelin concert
that's an experience they're gonna see a
bunch of YouTubers and listen it's the
holiday season what wouldn't you do for
your
kids
exactly it's amazing how much how
expensive stuff for kids is
listen but here's the where I win I win
because I don't have to take her a
[__] American Doll [__] B she
don't like that [__] and she don't even
talk about Mickey Mouse and
Disneyland no I go up to her and go you
want to go to Disneyland Orlando she'll
go not really thank you she done with
that [__] so I'm very [__] lucky hold
on I tell you what I'm not done with
putting in a good bet tonight it's
Monday night [__] the Jaguars are
giving 10 to [__] Cleveland who
Cincinnati who have no quarterback I
know the point spread started at 9 and a
half it went up to 10 but it's Monday
it's the holiday season they're looking
to stick a [__] a nail into your head
like Jesus on Monday you know what who
gives a [__] the under is low tonight
it's under 40 but anyway talk is cheap
let's talk to DraftKings about what's
crack
aling hey guys this epod episode is
brought to you by better help listen
what's up you crazy animals Uncle Joey
here to talk to you about mental health
especially during the holiday season
it's good it's a good time to give
yourself a little gift and get your head
checked what do I mean I mean listen
there's a lot of pressure stress what
are you going to get Grandma your cousin
don't like you you don't need this in
your life getting your mental health
together to start 2024 is the best thing
you could do for yourself and at better
help they'll make it happen they make
therapy incredibly easy how do I know I
was a customer everything is completely
online and suited to your schedule you
could talk to your therapist through a
video call a phone call a message you
could send them like a little kite a
pigeon whatever they're there for you
whenever and whatever works for you
better help can help you okay listen I
love
them I was with them for about six
months they helped me get the party
started and here I am coping with the
little anxiety I have in my life now
just taking a dep a breath of fresh air
what do you think I got that from
confucious better help to get started
just fill out the quick questionnaire
and get match with a licensed therapist
you can even switch therapists at any
time for free who's better than them
nobody listen in the season of giv give
yourself what you need with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com
Diaz today again betterhelp.com
Diaz to get 10% off your first month
that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz take care of yourself nobody's
gonna do it for you hey Uncle Joey here
I partnered up with DraftKings let me
talk to you about something an NBA game
could change in an instant no matter
what happens you know draftking sports
book has your back you ready for this
one this week beginning today Tuesday
the 5th new customers I'm going to let
you score 150 instantly in bonus bets
for just betting a fin $5 on basketball
win or lose you get the little small
buck and a half who's going to be better
than you this weekend you got bowl games
coming up you got NBA coming up you got
NFL coming up bet on
games makes everything a little bit just
more exciting I'm not talking to go
overboard just a small 20 10 15 just to
laugh at Grandpa and call your cousin
Momo it's tremendous so listen the party
starts with you it's the holiday season
DraftKings has offers all day for you to
got profit boost they do things nobody's
doing you understand me why because at
DraftKings you're the [__] King so
download draftking Sportsbook app now
pressing code Joey j o e y Joe y new
customers can get 150 instantly in bonus
bets for betting the small fin that's $5
on basketball like I said with
DraftKings you're the king as long as
you use C Joey but do me a favor you got
a gambling pal call 1-800 Gambler stay
out of OTB if you're in New York call
one no forget the one
8778 hope New York grab that pen
8778 New Hope New York or text Hope New
York 467 369 some we get back to you if
you're Virginia visit 1800 Gambler
listen but if you're straight I Got No
Problems download the draftking
Sportsbook app right now they got a
casino on there too Blackjack is King
live dealers knock yourself out draft
King sports book Co Joey Joe y happy
holidays we're back
anyway I did great yesterday on
DraftKings I had the Patriot and the
Chargers under 38 and a half and at
halftime they let me cash out and I only
gave up seven bucks and I like I'll just
take it just in case some weird [__]
happens did anything happen no it was
the the Patriots lost six to nothing
don't ever cash out mukar for seven
bucks I think n seven what if they came
back what if they came back New England
couldn't come back against [__] a
peee team yesterday who you kid
that's true dog I died a slow death
yesterday but I deserved it why I
deserve listen I'm the type of guy tell
you how it is if I deserve it I deserve
it why because when I woke up in the
morning before I left at like 10 I
didn't even know who was playing you
know there's a thousand games on
Thursday you lose count anymore I opened
up the thing and the first game
was Miami giving n and a half points to
the Washington commanders and the second
game was that was on
that was a game that oh
Detroit giving four and a half to New
Orleans and in New
Orleans
Jesus well guess what I did what did you
do I know one I know one of them as much
as I love [__] Detroit and I bet them
every time they
play I [__] bet New Orleans maybe
they lose by three and I covered by one
instead [__] Detroit won by five and
I got [__] in the [__] Muffler so
[__] but then I I mean listen I lose 25
bucks you know what I'm saying and then
I bet 25 on the over late night and that
came back and everybody was [__]
happy I did not touch that
uh Kansas
City whatever game interesting I was
watching something with my wife my wife
went upstairs I wanted to see what the
score was it was
2119 right away I go let me just check
DraftKings if you bet 25 bucks on Kansas
City on the money line it paid
110 don't think I wasn't tempted yeah I
thought they were going to come back
thank God I wasn't logged in it was
arithmetic four minutes left this is a
no-brainer this guy's going to throw two
touchdowns in [__] four minutes dog I
I turned it off because I wasn't logged
in anyway and as I went to log in and
just take the chance Columbus did
[__] Minnesota SC or whatever Green
Bay scored and I said [__] it thank God
I didn't it was thank God that they make
you log in see that's why I like
DraftKings gotu that saved me a million
[__] times but no my friend's going
to drive us he's got a company oh nice
pick us up here with all the moms we're
not stopping in New York City we're
gonna stop up north get something to eat
after we go through the traffic Friday
afternoon it's GNA be a busy [__] day
smart the sh the doors open at 5 we're
going to be there at
6 and instead of having to park and all
that [__] we just get out of the car and
walk in with the girls go in sit on our
tickets I'm not going to take edible or
nothing because I got to watch these
kids this is going to be pure torture
I'm going to have to put 3D glasses on
or something just to enjoy the [__]
thing then hopefully wait for jelly and
then hopefully take the girls backstage
and the moms and say hello and get the
[__] out of here hopefully be up be back
by like midnight we got a a 9:30
basketball game holy [__] you believe
what I'm talking about now compared to
what I used to talk about no
0 today you said you were kind of
tired I said to you that was the flight
the spot the night before it's rough
eating mushrooms and being on the road
the hotel I go think about I go how old
are you he said 35 I was doing that when
I was
55 and doing it three times a month and
doing eight podcasts a month God knows
what we're putting in our veins in those
[__] nights you know so you people
have to like I was on such a [__] go
that you know this is like paradise now
I'm like are you [__]
crazy so when we started we were doing
the podcast at 6 am so there were two
other days you were up early 6 am so it
those weeks I remember putting down like
30 [__]
pounds I I went up to
346 pounds when I baptized
Mercy wow well I was eating a lot with
my wife and [__] whatever but uh the
sleep was not there I was waking up
Monday and Wednesday morning with you at
4:45 then I would take the early flight
out on Thursday I would do radio on
Friday Saturday sleeping and then Sunday
I was going to bed for three hours I was
getting back to my hotel room at 1
getting picked up at
4:45 6:00 a.m. you know that's not sleep
you watch two laow on orders you eat a
slice of [__]
dominoes poison and then you burp and
fart all night and all a sudden the
alarm's going off it's time to wake up
ain't nothing there oh yeah that it was
I've done it a few times but it was it's
it's definitely like that early FL I
hate that early flight every time I do
it I get mad at you because I just I
just know but I know you're right but
it's getting up at that 7 a.m. flight is
rough listen in the words of red fox if
you got to do something
do it and get it the [__] over with
right over with so even whatever you're
in your bed that night and you're
relaxed your clothes are in the laundry
already they're percolating they're
taking the smell of STA and bars and
fast food joints you know it's it's a
it's really hard for people to not know
the the damage you put on as a comedian
when you start traveling you're flying
commercial these guys are flying [__]
private that's tremendous you go on
there you bring somebody to give you a
[__] tow rub but I'm talking about
commercial you know when you're roughing
it it's a a tough [__] world and it's
a world that like I said to you I burnt
out so much on flights I don't want to
see a [__] plane I don't need to go
anywhere right now I don't blame you at
all I was I actually was wondering that
though have you because like it seems
like there's like crazy [__] happening
on planes people going crazy people
[__] themselves did you ever see
like weird like a crazy thing happen on
a
plane when the guy tried to steal my
seat he wanted me to sit where he was
sitting at 5 in the morning and I was
like guy that's my seat yeah yeah yeah
yeah but my friend sitting there so if
you don't mind sitting my Street behind
the window I'm like get
up it was [__] early in the morning
it's a 5H hour flight the edible didn't
kick in yet and you're sitting in my
chair with [__] shoes on with no
socks on I will [__] stab you in the
[__] lung get the [__] up you
miserable [__] sucker and then the
[__] lady came and I'm like he's in
my chair and he left [__] a lot of [__]
like that but what's going on today is
unacceptable people jumping out of
planes and [__] New Mexico come on that
guy that guy did a [__] edible
because I tell you what I almost did
that a few times if you want me to lie
to you and sit here and say no I'm Uncle
Joey I could do this I could do that you
go [__] yourself Jack there was a couple
times I was on that plane thinking this
is my time and then I didn't say nothing
to
anybody I didn't complain I never told
anybody and then one day I was talking
to Ari and he goes oh my god did I tell
you what happened on the flight the
other day with Rogan no what happened
because we're sitting in first class and
the edible hit me
and he goes I really considered getting
off the
plane and I'm like does that happen to
you a lot he
goes sometimes and I go it's been
happening to me a lot lately like I
would sit on a plane go I'm excited and
then all of a sudden you're sitting
there you hear the engines going and
you're like this edible this might be
the time that the flight goes down you
start getting a lot of
[__] you do you've been on 90 flights
in two years you know there's got to be
a terrorist on this
flight if that kept happening why would
you do
it it's
fun it's psychological warfare you got
to be prepared in case the hmer coming
at you and that's they're playing heavy
metal music giving you
Edibles I am worried about that Jesus
Christ that you would freak out that
much you know I had my moment man God
for God forbid what I put myself through
when I was 17 16 emotionally unstable
and eating that window
pain and that's eight hours Leah of
beating and thinking and your heart
making noises and you know this is
somebody's Chasing You somebody's
outside somebody's in the closet that's
cocaine that came later but anyway it's
all the same thing there's something I
wanted to talk to you about because we
we don't really really this is just our
own little thing people don't even
understand what the [__] we're doing
this is about us I don't you know
everything else is background music you
say something wrong so but I don't care
about that listen it's all over I'm too
old you want to C if you didn't cancel
me with the one-legged woman you ain't
gonna cancel me now [__]
but want to talk to you about what's
going on with Matt R okay and it is so
crazy how people
I don't listen I was shooting a movie in
June and one of the young assistants we
were driving to the set with another
girl another guy and she goes Joey have
you ever worked with Matt R and I'm
like I don't even know who Matt R is
then the girl came up with his picture
and I go I'll tell you
what I remember meeting him and seeing
him somewhere but I'm not going to tell
you that I'm his best friend if that's
what you know right maybe seeing him at
the store and I remember that he was a
nice kid very respectful like he was
just a nice kid I don't know if I
watched him I'm not going to tell you I
watched him he was you know spect I
don't even
remember and then I started hearing his
name more and more and more and more and
then you
know it's not like I'm G to look up
[__] standup right now at that place
in my life you know and then more people
were asking me and then started seeing
clips of
him and you know he's just a young
goodlooking guy uh he has he's good as a
comic but he's got years to develop he's
young you know when he's 35 he's gonna
be a
killer yeah I think he's like 26 if I'm
not mistaken yeah so nine years he just
needs some heavy duty shows Chappelle
this that he needs to do a couple Puerto
Rican shows you know yeah he needs to
just so supposedly I watched that and I
watched that joke when he said that and
I remember silently saying to
myself at least he's got
balls you
know I love I liked his response did you
see what he what he tweeted tremendous
and right now I see all this [__]
hate for this kid that he's cancelled
listen if he's cancelled guy
he's canceling out with 15 mil that's
[__] you know that's
uh
$4,999 more dollars than you okay you
know he ain't going nowhere if he's
smart and I know they got a business
manager for him that dude is buying
something you know a [__] Apex
[__] missile or something and he's
good guys so don't worry about it he's
cancelled he's not cancelled he threw a
jab at people because some stand-ups
still exist from time to time and
there's some stand-ups that people
forget that when you become a standup
you're not a tool for society you're a
tool against Society you're telling your
take on it I don't want you to go out
there and you know be a [__] uh
revolutionary you know nobody ever and
that's what happens to Comics they
become revolutionaries that's you know
so he's got a lot to de
he's got the world by the balls and for
you people say he's
cancelled go back to your [__] uh
soup whatever kind of soup you're eating
tomato
soup go look into the word testosterone
in your life you know it's you can't you
got to stop canceling people this
movement has to [__] stop for dumb
reasons you know it's a joke it didn't
affect your life but anyway that was my
main
thing I'm not going to talk against
being woke or any of that [__] [__] that
that has nothing to do with that I just
think people are [__]
confused and it shows the
amount
of Lee I've cut my internet
use smart I had it and when I every once
in a while I look and I remember why
there's a girl I follow on Instagram I
don't have a crush on her I'm not
stalking I've never said a thing to her
she's an Italian girl she it's called
the Italian princess Lee the food this
girl eats you got to follow her and
she's
hysterical I don't know how much this
girl eats I don't know how she puts it
away I'm eating the pizza right now I'm
eating the mozzarel and P sandwich at 10
in the morning my [__] morning
sandwich you know it it goes all day it
ends at a restaurant with [__] 20 D
is Lee it is one of the most interesting
things I've seen the girl's got to be 24
[__] years old 25 years old I don't
know if she's an influencer I don't know
how many followers she has in my world
it's not like she's on there in a bikini
she's very respectful the reason why I
started following her was because she's
a young girl and she still speaks
Italian to her
grandmother that did something to me
like I moved back here nobody nobody's
on the streets yelling at a town no more
nobody even knows [__] Italian it's
like they should all be ashamed of
themselves but that's why I liked it
because he was talking to Italian to her
grandmother while they were disgusting
uh making [__] soup or something like
that go away [__] anyway you know
there's a lot there's a lot of bad stuff
but there's also like a lot of good
stuff online if you can find very
interesting she's tremendous
so you want I just looked at her thing
you know and I'm scrolling down the last
two videos she put up and right there in
the front right there some [__] guy
is like now I can see if you're telling
us you got nice tits or whatever you put
a picture up of a female you're gonna
get that whether they're in a dress or
they're in a bikini no this was like
this girl should be taken down all she
does is eat and she's eating the wrong
feet she should do this and everybody
was discussing her diet
and I'm like what the [__] are people
saying that I'm not [__]
watching i i i people have lost their
mind online and on both sides of it on
content and the comments that's why I
had to slow it down that's it I do my
Monday I post on my patreon and I keep
it light because it
is it is [__] Hell on Wheels out
there there was something else I saw
about a week ago and I'm like this
person has not done anything wrong at at
all you know and you just whatever you
post now I don't even look Lee I'm too
old to even look anymore you
just what do you think about like your
daughter watching
YouTube they have a restricted
upstairs my wife did something listen
eventually they're all going to watch
[__] YouTube and eventually there's a
a kid in the group that's a little old
she's 13 there's two of them there's one
of them that just says hello but there's
one of them that always looks at me and
smiles like she knows
something okay I thought about it for a
while she knows something and she always
goes like a you know listen they're
gonna see if she got a problem come to
me and talk to me you know what I'm
saying you know I'm go ahead I'm sorry
all I was going to say was not not even
like a problem with like you and seeing
your stuff I'm just saying like all the
all the shitty stuff on
YouTube set this computer on fire I'm
going set you on fire when I see you in
the car seat remember I used to burn you
with the lighter and when you'd hold the
joint I'd slip I'd make believe I'd slip
and I'd burn his fingers
how you did it every time you w always
light my finger were nice and high so
you didn't know what was happening and
you just freak me out and just do the
lighter and I jump I was half asleep
but
uh yeah that's that's where the [__] I'm
at guy that's awesome what was the last
question
brother just just about kids with
YouTube we were talking about that
listen kids are gonna see what they're
gonna see right told Mercy a long time
ago if she goes
hunting and she sees something she don't
like that's what happens for going
hunting you got a question you come talk
to me if some kid at school says
something to you come talk talk to me
we'll watch the video some kid at school
went there one day and showed it a Tik
Tok of Tom seura saying I dosed him and
I I did acid and Coke for 20 years you
know when she saw that what do you want
me to tell
her so I that's why it all LED for me to
opening up my trap about the weed I
don't want her upstairs thinking he did
heroin and Coke for 20 years so I got to
give her something I'm like [__]
poison give him something to believe in
you got to give him the
[__] the whammy you got to give him
the [__]
weed she knows I drink she know she sees
my behavior she knows I'm up with her
she doesn't know about heroin and
cocaine at all she knows a little bit
about Naros that's it I never watch
Godfather Harlem with him she watched
Scarface but she didn't watch the
cocaine thing oh just the beginning yeah
like the beginning or something else
then she doesn't really like it
she doesn't know that it would make her
mind blow up I wouldn't even take it
that it's not even in our world it's not
around here it's got nothing to do with
her or me or you you know I'm so happy
the relationship you guys have it's so
cool like you were saying earlier can
you imagine this is what what I'm
talking about with the basketball game
like she's getting old she's getting old
and like it's a different it's just cool
to see you so
happy it's not that I'm happy it's that
it was time brother it was time to this
makes me happy this makes me happy
seeing you once a week and talking to
you every night about comedy and [__]
I'm good at that I'm living vicariously
through you that's all I need I smoke my
weed at night and I'm like how would it
be if I drove with L the open
mic that'd be [__] crazy so yeah
that's where I'm at my friend I love you
buddy I love you too so thank you and
what do you got this week this week I
have one I have open mics every night
and then on Sunday day I'm in ROM
Massachusetts at uh the Asian Palace at
1:00 I'm doing a CH I'm doing my first
Chinese food restaurant all right well
that's good that's all you got next week
that's all I got next week uh got bunch
of stuff coming up but next that's all
that I have for this week I was thinking
about that New Year's Eve gig I love you
too much stay home mind your business I
was try to get you a new year's gig in
the city like a 10-minute guest spot 10
minutes Ain enough to risk your [__]
life God knows what they're going to do
in New York City and maybe you wake up
New Year's Day and nothing happen but
why come all the way to New York and go
M you know for the small 10 minutes do
10 minutes in front of the mirror with a
[__] uh fire happy New Year hat on
and one of those noise makers by
yourself after you're in [__]
training I need you in training
[__] oh of course three nights a
week like Uncle Joey we don't forget one
of the most important [__] things the
holiday season is coming I haven't eaten
them in about two weeks because I'm
getting ready for the holiday season but
at at Fun Factory
Farms either on Instagram or on
Telegraph telegram right go on
telegram go to Fun Factory farms and get
yourself a couple
cookies and you chill with Grandma over
the holiday nobody knows nothing you
could watch the [__] bowl games eat a
few mushrooms and put Uncle Joey Savage
and get 10% off that's how we're
rolling like I said a couple weeks ago I
went off to reservation with him like
Thursday Friday Saturday by Sunday it
was too deep I was deep deep deep in the
murky Waters and uh I took a break
that's it tonight was the first time I
ate Edibles since last Monday probably
wow you took almost a week off yeah
every time I eat these things like I
gotta clean out the [__] cabinet I
find myself eating candy
canes like the one night I must ate 10
bubblegum candy canes I don't even like
that [__] and then the next night I
attacked the regular candy canes on
Friday when I was H having that trip the
only thing I had in my room was rice
cakes I ate 21 rice cakes in about 15
minutes it was Flor worth they
caramel and chocolate it's all I had and
I couldn't go downstairs and then I just
didn't I'm still cheap I didn't want to
pay $50 to cold McDonald's
delivered so I just had the rice cakes
McDonald's when you're on mushrooms
would mentally destroy you in the middle
of that meal you think so I know so I
was just trying to get out of the you're
not supposed to eat McDonald's so while
you're think about that and then
actually that night you're going to
actually taste
a leg like it's going to taste like
somebody's leg and the mushrooms going
to take it to a different level and
that's the end of that [__] well
I'm glad I didn't get it then yeah me
too so get your life together no more
mushrooms no more fast food I know I
don't have fast food I don't ra I'd
rather you eat [__] uh the the corn
chips with the chili flavor on them
those are [__] good that's my idea
but anything tastes bad on mushrooms
yeah I don't eat I don't do anything
really sneak out of the room and smoke
some herb and [__] to calm that tiger
down and then that'll bring up some
appetite then you eat you go right to
bed maybe you might have to bang one out
with a little pinky in your ass hole you
never know it's a different world out
there I love you Lee let's talk and now
for a word from my
[Laughter]
sponsors
[Music]
hey and that's it I want to thank you
guys for listening but let me talk to
you about some listen it's time for you
to [__] see the devil this is the
time of the year where it's all over but
they're shouting the cousins are coming
over kids are coming over you need
something to help you get the way you
need to be that's where Uncle Joey comes
in that's where freeze pipe comes in
Joey what's freeze pipe like I told you
in the beginning of the show freeze pipe
is a bung that has a glycerin chamber
and every piece that you pop in the
freezer for just an hour so the piece
comes off okay it's like a j if James
Bond had a [__] bong this one would
be it okay as the when you're ready to
smoke you take it out of the freezer you
put it on the [__] bottom half you
fill up that [__] with the [__] devil
listen you take one hit as the smoke
passes through it it's cooled down by
over 300 degrees for the iciest hitch
you'll ever have you think you're
smoking bangit with a snowball up your
ass better than you nobody [__] Tucker
no matter how you like the smoke
bong dab Rings whatever freeze pipe is
here to chill everything out and if you
like blunts freeze pipe has a little
blunt blunt for you made with durable
glass these babies withand years of use
and Abu they ain't coming back at yet
they're not going to cancel you out
bongs don't have that option so do
yourself a favor this Hollywood this
Hollywood this
holly Day holiday SE do yourself a favor
take care of yourself shop the smoothest
pipes bubblers bongs more at the freeze
pipe.com and pressing code Diaz
DZ it's time to hit that freeze pipe to
loosen that mucus up to get 10% off your
entire order listen grandma don't want
that [__] little gift card to [__]
weather bees whatever it is Applebees
that shit'll make her [__] rare send
bub to get the party started go to the
freeze pipe.com and use code Diaz and
get 10% off I want to thank DraftKings I
want to thank better help but I want to
thank you Savages have a great week and
we'll see you [__] next week